dans le froid et sous les fenêtres de
l'inspection de l'éducation nationale
enseignants et syndicats locaux
expriment leur désaccord
ils sont opposés au projet de la ville
de trappes sur les rythmes scolaires un
projet qui conserverait le rythme actuel
de quatre jours et demi pour les
écoliers élémentaire mais qui
basculerait à quatre jours pour les
maternelles sans rattrapage des heures
supprimées
c'est un principe d'égalité inscrit dans
la constitution donc il n'est pas a
fortiori sur un territoire comme
celui-ci acceptable que l'on diminue le
nombre d'heures d'enseignement au delà
de ça ce que nous demandons c'est le
retour à quatre jours les quatre jours
et demi sur trappe
n'ayant absolument pas fait la preuve de
leur d'être satisfaisante des rythmes
différents maternelle et en élémentaire
une première qui nécessitait l'accord du
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
justifier cette innovation le maire de
la ville assure qu'il cherche la
meilleure solution pour les enfants est
garanti que rien n'est encore décidé
vous pourrez avoir des éléments
différents en temps et en rythme mais
par rapport aux primaires il ya des
enfants en maternelle surtout la toute
petite section qui sortit son qui sont
fatigués donc est-ce qu'on a une réponse
ou pas on ne peut pas décider ça tout
seul donc attendre la réponse du
ministre pour continuer à manifester
leur opposition enseignants et syndicats
prévoit d'intervenir lors du prochain
conseil municipal mardi le ministère lui
n'a pas encore répondu à la demande de
dérogation formulées par la mairie